the thing that's really depressing is we
have no common culture anymore do we we
have zero common culture we don't watch
the same TV shows we don't watch the
same Sports no one goes to the theater
at all we don't even go to the movie
theater anymore we live stream certain
things that we like or more likely we're
not even live streaming on the same
platform the conservatives are live
streaming on daily wire plus the libs
are live streaming on Disney plus very
few people subscribe to both daily wire
plus and Disney plus maybe some people
have Netflix and Hulu and maybe but
increasingly even in the platforms that
we're subscribing to we just have
nothing we barely we don't speak the
same language words don't mean the same
thing for the conservatives and for the
lips